one thing i gather from this
is that like i'm interested in in
the audacity of like chasing an
outrageous goal right and and
kind of the mindset that's required to
do that
and you know my belief and my sense
is that you would agree with this is
that you have to
first of all you have to have the
confidence that you can accomplish
something like this like deep deep down
and then you have to just or even if
you're you have some insecurities you
still have to act
as if you have to proceed accordingly
and with so many moving pieces money
crew like all these things that have to
come together in order for you to pull
this off
you can't wait until all that's figured
out because the clock's ticking and
you've set this date like you have to
just presume that this is happening
right and
just say it's going to get worked out
you know you're doing the footwork the
legwork like literally in your training
and whatever you're doing on the phone
to like pull these things elements
together but that
that belief like you have to be the
lighthouse because
if you don't believe it and have that
confidence how can you
expect the ceo of natamu and all these
crew people who are going to sacrifice
their personal time
to support you in this like they have to
they have to
they get that from you right so you have
to carry that vibration
yeah i i think it all came down to like
i desperately wanted this i wanted it
for a lot of reasons
i wanted it one for the outreach for the
advocacy it meant a lot to me to
to start being a force for
positive change and two i was lost i'd
come out of
15 years more in the restaurant industry
and i
didn't feel like i wanted to do that
anymore and
as much as i enjoyed that time in my
life and i was good at what i did
it doesn't give you a lot of skill sets
outside of it and
i knew whatever i did next i wanted it
to be something that fed my soul
and moving my body does and pushing the
limits of what i can do physically
so i just kept doubling down that this
is what i had to do i
had to get this together and a lot of it
was just
faith that it would come together and
again going back to that
mantra that my mom instilled in me you
can do anything you set your mind to
and it you know it's easy to sit here
and say that it just was that easy but
there was a lot of discouragement there
were a lot of times that
i i probably wasn't too pleasant to be
around at home
and you know my fiance was really
she's an amazing human to put up with me
through a lot of that because there were
there was a lot of times where i was
scared you know how was i going to get
this together and and then there was
that moment you know going back to the
the plan of once i did get everything on
board
i still didn't have the logistics
together uh-huh and then that all came
to a head over christmas you know i left
again
march 15th and over christmas we were
back in austin
and i was having a pretty big freak out
i didn't have a route
i didn't have a crew vehicle i didn't
have
a crew chief i didn't even really have
my nutrition plan yet
and luckily the support of my in-laws
and my fiance and her sister
we all sat down around the table and we
started figuring it all out and just
checking those things off and
it was the first time where i realized
how much a team mattered
again going back to my career in the
restaurants i had
i was a good leader but i wasn't a
really great
delegator and i wasn't really good at
trusting in others a fiercely
independent person
just have been my whole adult life if
not even in childhood
and that was my first place where i felt
overwhelmed and i had i needed help
and they all came together so selflessly
and without me having to beg for it they
did they sensed it that i needed it and
we sat down
and we broke off chunks for everybody to
take care of
and within a week span most things were
in order and had i continued to try to
do everything by myself
yeah you know march 15th a little bit of
a control freak
i don't know if it's r yeah i guess it's
control freak it's not that i don't
believe other people are capable of
things i just have a hard time asking
yeah i think is more where it comes from
and i don't know if that's just again
only child
just like really independent i don't
know where that really comes from but
i'm glad to say that through this
process i'm much less that way
yeah well the route part of it seems
like it shouldn't be that hard to figure
out because so many people have done
you know 300 people have done this and
they share their routes right aren't
there like there are like specific
routes where they're like this
if you're gonna do it like this is what
this is the way you do it yeah the
official route
is from san francisco i want to say it's
from san francisco city hall
to tavern on the green in
central central park yeah um i
when we sat down again at this table at
christmas i really wasn't sure what my
route was going to be
i was looking at everything part of me
at one time really wanted to do it
through the deep south being from
georgia i feel like it's a place that i
could
talk to people in a way maybe others
couldn't
and we started looking but then someone
put in in google maps you know
la to new york city and just seeing it
on the map i was like well that
nobody denies that you ran across the
country if you do that it's definitely
the longest route
and at that point it's like that's what
i want to do i know it's longer you know
you go other spots and go 2600 miles
where this one was just under 3 200.
and um we found that there was a race in
2011
that some frenchmen put on and it went
it was called lanny la to new york and
we found some pdfs that they had left
online
of a route and so we took that and we
started laying that down on strava maps
and built out my my route because my the
biggest thing i was worried about
was sometimes it's really hard to judge
what is the safest route
where's the shoulders where where's the
most optimal road to run on the site i
mean i'm on the side of the road every
day for 12 hours that's a lot of time
for some
something to go wrong and so that was
yeah that was how we found the route it
ended up being
something that was weighing on me but
once we found that it alleviated that
and then chris shelley's father he took
the time to put it all into strava maps
and then also double check it with
google
earth and stuff of that nature to just
make sure it looked right
right yeah it's interesting i never
really thought of it in that much detail
like it's not
necessarily like the best route isn't
necessarily the most direct route
obviously you want to stay off the busy
roads where there's lots of traffic and
it's dangerous but
if a busier road has a broader shoulder
than a country road where you're going
to be running in
uneven gravel and there is no shoulder
then how
you know like yeah you might want to go
with the busier road i prefer the
shoulder
yeah yeah interesting um all right and
how do you begin to put
the nutrition plan together to figure
out like how you're gonna eat like how
much you're gonna eat and what your
your stomach's gonna be able to tolerate
i mean i know you have
like an iron gut and all of that but
still that's
that's got to be a tricky equation to
sort out it was and i'm not a
nutritionist
you know i i i love food i understand
food i understand food on a higher level
in restaurants and such but what it's
going to take
to fuel me exerting that much
was was not my specialty
but luckily in my corner was uh jackie
shelly's sister and she just the year
before had done the appalachian trail
plant-based
and so coming into it and she also had
gained some plant-based nutrition
certification
in that time and is someone who aspires
to get into more plant-based nutrition
and she put it together and she's a
spreadsheet whiz
and the idea was high fat high
carbohydrate
uh we figured i would need but we
thought we'd start with about 5000
calories a day
and ramp it up to about 10. uh-huh when
we got out there we ended up just like
day one it was 7
000 and then eight thousand pretty much
another
month in and it stayed there so between
seven eight thousand calories
but yeah that was i left that on her and
i just had faith that she could she
could pull it together
and i mean it didn't i didn't have to
have faith she's a very capable human i
knew she would
and yeah she devised the meal plan
and a lot of it was made up in smoothies
i had a thousand calorie smoothies that
i had four times a day
like a lot of coconut oil like high fat
yeah coconut milk
chia seeds bananas carrots kale
powdered peanut butter and soylent we
used some soylent milk replacer in there
um
it just really rounded things out and
made sure we got
the calories where we needed it and what
kind of real food were you chewing on
uh in the mornings i'd start off with a
bowl of oatmeal
and with maple syrup and chia seeds and
bananas a big bowl of that a cup of
coffee
and then i stopped every five miles
right so if i the first five i'd have
that first smoothie second one a big
bowl of fruit
third one smoothie and then like more
more carb
starchy cold pasta we went through a lot
of things for the things i would eat
during the middle of the day
i started off i come up with this
kind of vegan bond me and it was just
sliced bread
with tofu hummus cilantro
and like cucumbers or something like
that and
quickly i did not want bread bread was
not working for me
i think it was more because they were
pre-making the sandwiches and got soggy
and i just
couldn't do the soggy bread so we ended
up doing every rendition of that
possible it was
within it was in tortillas it was just
loose in a bowl
and then we moved on to cold pasta and
vegan quesadillas and mac and cheese
or vegan mac and cheese a little bit and
then um
yeah just stuff like that starchy
carving right things and then at the end
of the day
i would have uh like a camping meal
outdoor herbivore and i would have a
double portion of that cooked down with
coconut milk so the coconut milk went a
long ways and
peanut butter no gels or any other kind
of well you
one of the things you said was you
didn't drink you really didn't drink any
water
right like you were it was all
electrolyte drinks yeah it was scratch i
used scratch the whole way
um through some reading we had found
some people in the past who had said
they didn't drink much water
there were two things that jackie
recommended that i was like no i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna need to do that and
one was
that i wouldn't drink water and two was
that i would need
that i would need uh eight every five
miles
i thought i could make it fifteen twenty
miles every day without yeah and those
two things she was completely right on
but i
i get the the aid thing i think the no
water thing
like i don't understand that it was
calories each uh
each of my water bottles that i carried
on me most time i carried a hydration
vest with two water bottles
and each one had 60 calories in it and
you just
when you're doing something like this
you need to get those calories whenever
you can wherever you can
and it was replacing the salts so
i just stuck with it we just found that
at the end of the day when we would
tally up how many calories i was getting
we kept a pretty good log of that
had i not been drinking scratch all the
time we would have been in a deficit
where with it it was just allowing
everything to flow
i mean day one we started that and we
just kept going with it so when you're
depleting
yourself of salts at that kind of a
rapid rate
it's like too easy to get hypo neutrinia
is that
the idea yeah and i sweat a lot so
it was a fear and i you know in races
i've always been one that
um i take salt tabs about every hour
i didn't out there the scratch was
taking care of it so we just stuck to
the scratch
it did the job and it was one of those
things if it's not broke don't fix it
right and um it held up the whole time
so this whole thing comes together you
get the funding you get the sponsors you
get the crew
you get the van wrapped you got datsy
you know everybody
uh is is on board and i joined you for
that first day um in huntington it was
huntington right yeah
we ran from the pier and uh it was cool
like there was a whole
scene of people like there was a it was
there was a lot of you know structure
and formality to this whole thing like i
was like wow this guy's got his [ __ ]
together
um this is really happening uh it was
really fun
because we hadn't met um to get to know
you a little bit that morning
um and then at some point i was like all
right dude i'm out like i gotta turn
around and go home and you just i just
watched you like run off into the
distance and i just thought man that guy
like what an adventure lies ahead for
you like
you know that there was it was so
exciting that morning but
how long before that wears off and the
you know the reality starts to dawn on
you uh
morning waking up day two